we're pretty much in shock every day
that we come to work and we just realize
how
well we get along and you know there's
no not a black sheep in the group
and you know no one gets on anyone's
nerves and no one gets picked on more
than the other
no no
the boys thought it'd be funny if i walk
through with this as part of the bit
funny
for me i personally have a group of
friends that's
very close to me and we really look out
for each other and
jennifer's right see what if everybody's
okay
i mean in that way it's very similar to
my life
okay here we go
quiet please no talk no talking please
all the work hey everybody this is
rachel and
another lincoln high survivor this is
everybody this is chandler
and phoebe and joey and you remember my
brother ross
which one of these guys would be your
friend in real life oh i can't say that
oh in real life the character-wise
ross that's he's sweet and down to earth
and doesn't have that many issues
that's true you do have another child
yeah
with another woman that's a different
issue right you're this way excuse me
this
they're usually really funny and they're
just not thinking today
this is the part of the show that lisa
told me she likes the best is that you
don't always have to be nice to your
friends you can be mean to your friends
i can't maybe
oh is today the day you're gonna tell
them about you too
yeah my dad's birthday i decided to give
him a stroke
yes definitely people can play with each
other that way
although i'm gonna kill them all this is
finished
oh that'd be great i think it's nearer
to the premiere date right yeah
sort of on pins and needles to see how
it's going to do and how well it's going
to do
i mean it's hard to work on something
that long and not having this suit
um actually david do you want me to put
this somewhere for you
yeah do you do you need it no no no okay
matt was playing
oh okay um
yes of course we have no idea what's
gonna happen
here comes the bigger bigger comedy this
is just a bit
don't get nervous don't be afraid okay
thanks i'm sorry i'm just being
interviewed and you know what i can't
concentrate i'm sorry i'm just going to
get through it
i gotta get through porky
okay so anyway what were you asking
martha i'm sorry it's okay
what were you saying i can't think of
one other thing you were saying my own
pins and needles about the show yes i am
the needless about this show
oh no oh over there
you